and so really my generation brings
literally nothing to the table because
of this mentality be happy the me me me
generation and it's because um My
Generation so I got social media when I
was like I don't know 14 13 um it's
getting younger nowadays you know they
they started to mess up she's 32 now so
that's you know so she got the social
media really took off in her 20s and she
got diluted too we all got we all got
freaking crazy and just believe all
these lies that they tell us in the
media and I really just think social
media has really messed us up and don't
get us messed up from social media I
don't know why I mean I could tell you
why women we just believe anything so we
believe that we're queens and amazing
and this is the future we could just
have these Happy Divorce parties guys no
no this is all wrong